so we're here today for content creation
but before you start making lots of
content for your newly online course I
want you to take a step back and think
do I really need to be creating content
right now am I ready if your course is
set up and you really feel you need your
own content your own video that's great
and I will tell you a little bit about
that today but there are amazing
resources and I've worked with two teams
this week putting together lists and
resources for you I worked with we
create edu a collective of content
creators on YouTube and I'm gonna put a
link in the video description to the
spreadsheet we made and this features
diverse fields from history and
linguistics to Natural Science you can
find a lot of content for your courses
there also this week I worked with the
American Society for biochemistry and
molecular biology and we made an
incredible overview of how to get
started with online teaching and
learning and we put a bunch of resources
so if you're in those fields
there's many links and lots of things
that you can use already but you've
decided to go for it you want to create
your own content think about the
simplest way you could do it you know
you're used to maybe walking in front of
a lecture room and maybe writing on the
board maybe showing some slides perhaps
you can just make a screen recording of
you talking through those slides so path
of least resistance here let's try to
make our content in a way that we're
comfortable with that will be easy for
us the first time through if you find
you're about to download a new software
and get really deep maybe that's not
what you want to be doing this week in
video 3 of this series I talked about
doing synchronous sessions with your
students and you can use an office hours
or a problem-solving session record it
and use little chunks of it as your
course material you'll be interacting
with the students so you'll get
questions and that's really great
content to deliver and if you're going
to do a synchronous office hours anyway
why not use it as your course content in
video 3 we also talked a little bit
about live streaming and I showed you
how to do it with maybe a whiteboard
behind you since the easiest way to do a
live stream is just taking a recording
of you and your surroundings but if you
have this PowerPoint lecture that you
were just dying to present you can do
your live stream provide your students
with the slides say now go to slide
three say what you wanted to say and
pause for questions the students can
type their questions into the live
stream you can answer them in real-time
and you can present this wonderful
interactive version of your PowerPoint
lecture the live stream remember it goes
directly into YouTube which has an
editor you can chop up your video into
smaller segments you can just use pieces
of it that you want you can put it
online as is without any processing
whatsoever so that's a very convenient
way to get content online quickly okay
for audio my colleague Mary puffins Roth
says that the air pods Pro are a really
great way if you want to just do office
hours I have done office hours on just
the little white earbuds that come with
the Mac plugged into my computer and the
audio is just fine it's not the greatest
thing you've ever heard but recording in
the room is kind of an off sound and
people do not tolerate bad audio as well
as they'll tolerate bad visuals so you
want to get the audio sounding at least
tolerable so people want to listen to it
so I don't recommend or talking directly
into your computer use a headset or if
you want to go a little fancier I'm
wearing my rode love mic right now
so comes in this little pouch and I have
it hooked up to my phone since I'm
filming on my camera but you can plug
this directly into your computer and set
up a screen recording software to record
you through your love mic this is about
70 bucks but my preferred is this blue
snowball here and there's other
different brands but this is the one
that I use it's a podcast microphone and
this is just a pop filter in front of it
that prevents my C's from sounding too
too hard and things like that it is
absolutely beautiful sound and
many of the animated biochemistry videos
that I do about proteins if you want to
sample some of that audio I'm using that
mic for this and I use this mic
throughout this series okay so for your
quick videos if you're recording
something do the lighting as best you
can you don't have to have a fancy setup
like this I record off a doc cam I used
to just put two lights like this on
either side shining at my piece of paper
to illuminate it a little bit and my
early videos they're not perfect but
they're absolutely fine the students
could see what I was drawing so you
don't need a fancy lighting set but do
make sure there's no weird shadows or
anything before you get started
always just do a quick test run of your
recording to make sure things look just
about the way you want right now I'm
just using the lights in the room and I
think you can see me just fine so you
don't have to get crazy or fancy with
this most of my videos feature
hand-drawn structures because I do
organic chemistry and so I like to draw
everything out it's the way I'm
comfortable it's the way I'm very quick
at doing this I don't need to generate
big powerpoints with animations I can
just hand draw and use my screen
recording software so I'm going to show
you a little demonstration of what I'm
using to do my hand-drawn stuff and I'll
show you a quick hack where you can plug
your iPad directly into your computer
and do a quick drawing that way I've
gotten a lot of questions about my
document camera this is the most
expensive part of my setup this is a
Luminex ladybug DC 125 and it lists at
about 250 I believe I got it on sale
seven years ago for 160 and it has just
been the cornerstone of my online
education I like to draw it makes things
easy
I can produce videos very quickly and
that's a real benefit to this another
benefit is that it comes with its own
software so what you're seeing on the
screen is just a live video of what I'm
doing here so I can be drawing this I
could be gesturing to this I could even
put a piece of paper over this and do a
slow reveal of something that I already
drew so this allows me to really create
content
very quickly it projects like this and
then I record my screen with my screen
recording software so you see a theme
here if I go into my screen recording
software I can just set it up to be
recording the the desktop and recording
from my blue snowball here and when I
press this button I'll jump over to this
view and then I can talk about it into
my mic and later I can just chop out
things if I don't think the students
need to see me drawing all these
structures I'll just chop it out and
talk about the structures and so that's
what you can see in some of my organic
chemistry videos now if you're not in
the market today for a 250 dollar
document camera you can get cheaper ones
however I also have a hack for you that
just involves using your iPad so I've
done this in a pinch before using Adobe
sketch I can record this screen so I'll
set up my recording to record so I don't
need to do the desktop now but I can
record from this iOS device so if you
have an external device you can hook
into this there are also things like
writing tablets I don't use those so I'm
not really gonna get into it but I just
want you to know that they exist so I
won't record video because them not
sitting in front of the computer right
now I'll record my audio from my blue
snowball and I can go ahead and set this
up it'll count down to record and then I
can go ahead and talk while I draw on my
iPad and whenever I'm done I can finish
my recording so now you can see the
frame from my iPad loaded in maybe I
don't want all these brushes on here
there are key commands to crop your
screen so you can just take out anything
you don't want to see and I'll go ahead
and just play it and so you can see me
drawing if I wanted to cut the video I
can just press T and it will trim my
Clips so I can cut out pieces very
readily and so that's just a wonderful
way to get something down really quickly
if you want to draw you don't want to
buy a duck cam and you have an iPad
handy well thanks for joining me today
this is my last video of this series and
I made it through a video a day for a
week so I'm really excited right now
the take-home message from this video is
just if you want to create content do it
as simply as possible and remember that
in the video description I'm gonna put a
few links so that you can see all the
other great content out there and decide
if this is an area you really want to
delve into right now thanks again for
joining me